un acuerdo para detener los avances
nucleares de irán después de hablar a
puerta cerrada con su aliado más cercano
israel pidió a eeuu y a la comunidad
internacional que usen toda su fuerza en
contra del programa atómico de la
república islámica
woods las palabras no detendrán a irán
señor presidentes la diplomacia tampoco
lo detendrá wilson stop pero la
percepción de byd en la diplomacia
siempre será el camino
se trata de un interés de seguridad
vital tanto para israel como para eeuu y
diría que también para el resto del
mundo continuaré trabajando con israel
para contrarrestar otras amenazas de
irán en toda la región incluyendo el
apoyo al terrorismo el programa de
misiles balísticos y la proliferación de
armas a terroristas
hayden también espera que bajo su
administración el acuerdo nuclear con
irán se ha actualizado luego de que el
presidente de donald trump lo abandonara
en 2018 otra de las movidas importantes
del mandatario estadounidense en la
región es su deseo de conciliar una paz
duradera entre el estado de israel y el
pueblo palestino
o la idea de una solución de dos estados
a lo que el primer ministro israelí
reaccionó guys and with view
enviamos un mensaje de paz con usted a
todas las naciones de la región
incluidos por supuesto los palestinos
israel quiere la paz y cree en ella
nunca cederemos ni un centímetro de
nuestra seguridad estamos obligados a
ser cautelosos en cada paso pero si
cualquier nación quiere hacer la paz con
nosotros les decimos a ellos salhón
ya lo
como el primer presidente estadounidense
en hacer un viaje directo desde israel
arabia saudita pese a la oposición por
su reunión con el príncipe heredero
mohamed bin salman payden planea
encontrar más aliados para hacerle
frente a irán y ser el puente de unión
entre israel y los países árabes del
golfo